alright let's answer some audience
questions the first question today is
from Nick and that question is what are
your thoughts when someone says well we
will have to just agree to disagree I've
been in a number of conversations where
ultimately someone ends up saying this i
don't really like it I mean I I tend to
not like the it we'll just have to agree
to disagree when someone says it to me
because I feel like typically it said to
me when I've challenged someone's belief
with fact they don't like the facts and
they're basically just trying to end the
conversation by saying hey you know what
it's a disagreement I don't think we're
going to resolve it today at the same
time there have been times where I feel
like I'm at an impasse with someone
where I've tried to explain to them with
all of the facts that I'm aware of why
their belief about something is wrong
and they just don't understand what I'm
saying and I will sometimes say let's
agree to disagree but I say it almost
sarcastically where I'm like listen I
want to talk to you anymore clearly this
isn't going anywhere so I'm not actually
saying it to say I'm satisfied with
agreeing to disagree i'm sort of saying
i don't think you even have the
competency to understand what it is that
i'm explaining to you yeah 10 years ago
you never saw this problem now these one
of things called smartphones replica put
facts r in someone's face and see see
the anger of their their ignorance but
it doesn't even matter I mean I know
what you're saying we're before smart
phones you would get into an argument
with someone and you had no way of
pulling a device out and just actually
finding the facts I'm not convinced that
being able to pull out a smartphone and
quote find the facts actually helps to
resolve that many arguments because
number one you can find some source on
the Internet to back up almost any
assertion or belief and number two many
times people are often not that
influenced by facts at least in the
conversations I have which is why I say
to people many times I'm not huge on
even engaging in political debate like
when I'm out socially because it tends
to get very very awkward sort of
negatively tinged the entire rest of the
evening and very little is accomplished
in my experience I don't
no if you engage in political debate
with friends or family I end up on my
soapbox every now and then working to
people but I think what you do in the
end here when you agree to disagree
sarcastically it's it's like any good
news not compromise i was told is where
both parties walk away feel that the
effect but that the problem is there's
no uh sometimes on opinion that makes
sense or or sometimes when we're talking
about a deal yeah the whole everybody
ends up unhappy when there's a good
compromise thing does make sense to me
but when we're talking about the
empirical reality of something this
whole we should both end up unhappy with
some kind of middle ground knows there's
right and wrong when it comes to things
they can actually be determined
empirically and that's why I sort of
struggle with let's agree to disagree
someone usually is walking out there
with some belief that is completely not
based in fact when that term is used so
I do admit that I sometimes use it I
think it's ridiculous and when i use it
i'm basically saying it as sort of I'm
surrendering to the fact that we're not
getting anywhere else